this great big story was made possible
by wells fargo established 1852
re-established 2018.
located in altenburg austria is a
benedictine abbey with an unusually
beautiful crypt
the abbey is filled with well-known
areas such as the striking marble room
the library the chapel and the medieval
monastery however the one area that
stands out is the abbey's crypt
crypts are often dark subterranean homes
of the dead but this crypt is bright and
its walls are adorned with beautiful art
the detailed frescoes were painted by
austrian artist paul schroger in the
18th century
at a distance the imagery appears cheery
however death is in the details
[Music]
one wall features a skeleton holding an
arrow aimed at cherubs two already slain
at his feet
intricate images of roman gods in
skeleton form are also painted within
massive murals
[Music]
altenberg abbey was built in 1144 but
has been the site of numerous invasions
throughout history
in 1645 a swedish attack rendered it in
need of severe repair
[Music]
but despite these trials the abbey has
remained active and is a unique
experience for all that come to see it
[Music]
you